قاعده مرور الجويه قد تفجر الصراع مجددا
في السودان بين المكونات العسكريه
المختلفه اهالي مروي تفاجئوا بعشرات
المركبات العسكريه التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع تنتشر في مدينتهم وتطوق المطار
تظاهر رفضا لما جرى وتاييدا للقوات
المسلحه واعاده تمركز القوات
يخالف مهام نظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات لجان الامنيه
المركزيه والولائيه
واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما الى المزيد من
الانقسامات والتوترات التي ربما تقود الى
انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
موقف القوات المسلحه نفته قوات الدعم
السريع وصفه تحركاتها بالطبيعيه والتي تم
تنسيقها مع قياده القوات المسلحه ضمن
تاديه مهامها وواجباتها
سبق لقائد قوه الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
دقلو ان وعد بحل الخلافه مع الجيش والذهاب
الانتخابات النزيهه الدوردا دايرين
انتخابات حره نزيهه الشعب السوداني ان شاء
الله جاب لنا
لاجل غير مسمى فالاطراف العسكريه لم تتفق
ولم تدمج قوات الدعم السريع في صفوف الجيش
تقدر اعداد قوات الدعم السريع بالالاف
بدات تتشكل عام 2003 اسست رسميا عام 2013
وتعمل تحت التسلسل قيادي بموجب قانون خاص
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات